do you see uh parallels between the
cultural revolution and what's happening
today
because you know we that a lot of people
call what's happening with cancer
culture struggle sessions
well so it's it's this is something that
has been people have made that
comparison before and it's it creates a
lot of controversy because there aren't
roving
bands of red guard killing people yet
but i think they were like
the right guard they were literally
murdering just people in large numbers
uh so the the thing the quest the real
question is
how does a society get to that point
what
breeds that uh and
so we do need to be vigilant because if
this happened once before
in human history it could happen again
well like like how many people were the
red guard killing
uh numbers of people who died in the
cultural revolution it varies
probably maybe
15 to 20 like the high end is 20 million
as an as a as a estimate of how many
people died during the cultural
revolution there was no period among
these revolutionaries where they knew
they were in the cultural revolution it
was only with hindsight we looked back
and then said here's where it's
our culture revolution was a specific
campaign by mao okay it was called the
culture revolution to eliminate the four
olds which was old thought old culture i
forget all the old ones
i i just mean like was there a p was
there a point where mao was like okay
today is the day we start
go and kill people well he was like
today we must start the cultural
revolution to
you know basically rectify the culture
of the party so there was an actual like
start date for that
and it ended when he died and people
were like after a really long time
a long time yeah it was it was i i
remember speaking to one chinese person
who
was alive at the time and they said it
was basically we talk about like the 10
years that we went crazy
i mean it was really bad although in
some areas it was worse than others and
like by
that by the end mao was kind of like not
doing well so it was
it kind of petered out but like
literally you had to quote mao's little
red book to like be able to
buy food you know like you're like get
on a bus you have to say a quote from
mao
yeah yeah but like you know the
there are i understand why some people
see parallels with what's happening in
the us today
i think the there's a few big
differences in the and the chief one is
that
the us government protects freedom of
speech
and you know even if you get cancelled
on twitter and and
kicked off of youtube and you know your
books are banned from the publisher like
you're not going to be arrested you're
not going to be
there's no legal mechanism to send you
to prison that's not that's not sure
there is
they just lie okay so but that's i mean
i mean you
take a look at the the antifa riots
throughout the pacific northwest
we just learned there was an
investigation that found 31 of 90 had
their charges dropped and many dismissed
with prejudice
which according to one expert this is
extremely rare for them to actually do
this
some of these were felony charges where
antifa literally assaulted
an officer their charges are dropped now
when it comes to
the the out group which would be these
you know trump supporters at the capitol
you have the instance of some people
this is really interesting cause i'm
seeing journalists say this the shaman
guy with the horns
apparently he argued in court the cops
waved him in
and it's on video the cops are waving
and people are following the cops waving
and the cops open the door
not everybody who went in the building
were shoving their way through police
and fighting with cops
there were many circumstances where the
doors were just opened up now i think
obviously everybody who went in the
building was dumb and it was a huge
mistake for these people
but you take a look at how after
you know six seven months of rioting and
cities being burned down
and these anti-foot people i mean the
vice president was soliciting donations
to bail her out
so we we can say there's no legal
mechanism in a sense but there is a
cultural mechanism that guarantees
if you're far leftist and you burn down
a city
it is very likely that you will face no
cultural repercussions
none whatsoever i mean they're not being
targeted by law enforcement as
terrorists
they're being the vice president's
raising money joe biden's own staffers
were raising money to get them out but
if you're a trump supporter
who was just in dc you're this woman
she's a psychological operations officer
in the army
she was simply attending a speech she's
been she's under investigation one guy
was a music a rapper he's an artist his
label dropped him for simply being in dc
when this happened
so that's what's scary to me we can say
oh but we have a constitution sure but
what happens when the federal government
just lies
and then you have the entirety of the
establishment democratic left saying
good they want to do a commission on
these people now i think it's
it's you know maybe the fear is perhaps
a bit pessimistic
but maybe the fear is that they learn
from what these other countries did and
how to avoid
you know falling into certain traps they
don't want to kill people they want
control they don't want
to look like the villains themselves
especially in an age of social media and
instant transmission of information so
they use clever manipulation to make
sure their political dissidents are
stripped destroyed and removed
and that's what's happening i do think
that it is different in the us
like if the cultural revolution happened
in the u.s it could not happen the same
way that it happened in china because we
do not have
uh like it's not we have guns well well
besides that like
the whole mechanism is like started in
china by the state like it's started by
the chinese communist party it's like
top down but
also the cult of personality mao hat
which doesn't work but like
but you're certain i think that's a
personality
i think that like in the us the
mechanism is
like if you have these tech companies if
you have
like uh like the democratic party or
like you have
you have this like cultural mechanism
for it that is like a different
manifestation but it could
like the psychologically there are
similarities i would say and
especially in terms of like things like
the you know reporting on people like
the
like there are things that that could
happen with this
cancel culture stuff that's going on
that could follow
like the course of the cultural
revolution without
being a thing that is done by the yeah
or done by the state exactly or like you
know but it could have like the same
you can have neighborhood watch
committees where you know or you know
everybody's looking at whatever you know
you're pulling up what you said on
twitter 20 years ago
you know perhaps we're just not at that
stage of what the cultural revolution
was yet
but we do have you know just recently
the it was christopher wray
i believe it was fbi saying you know
domestic terror
coming you know i i don't know if he
specifically called out trump supporters
but
i think he said you know far right
domestic terrorist the biggest threat
we're facing
you've got the democrats saying trump
supporters and q anon
they're claiming that they need to keep
these troops surrounding dc with razor
wire fences
and these and the and you know razor
wire and these fences
because of the these conspiracy theories
about trump's true inauguration
you are getting from mainstream press a
narrative
over and over and over again of who the
evil is calling for a
calling it the one six commission they
want a 9 11 style commission on what
happened at the capitol they're acting
like it was on par with 9 11.
and they're continually demonizing trump
supporters populist right-wingers
conservatives
to the point where you know we've
mentioned it several times now echelon
insights interviewed
democrats what is you know of these
things how would you rate your level of
concern
the top concern among democrats is trump
supporters
white nationalists white supremacy and
among
trump supporters among republicans it's
illegal immigration taxation support for
the police
very run-of-the-mill conservative
positions it seems like the narrative
we're getting from the mainstream press
about how bad and awful
the right is in this country is reaching
that level where
i mean people i think are ready to
person go insane so perhaps at the point
where you'll see red guard going around
literally murdering murdering people
but we are getting danger to that point
where i believe it's entirely possible
you will see the democrats come out and
straight up say
arrest them all every single one because
we're already getting that point nicole
wallace on msnbc said
if they were in a different country
would have blown them up by now with a
drone strike
what wouldn't mitch mcconnell think
trump should be arrested for what he did
we have an article from the root where
they said republicans are enemy
combatants
that we must treat as enemy combatants
the route
in 2018 according to news whip was the
number one publication on the left
now the right got substantially more
engagements but they were still number
one
what happens when you have prominent
democratic uh uh politicians
people like ocasio-cortez saying ted
cruz you tried to get me
murdered and they're telling this to
people over and over again where do we
go in a year
perhaps right now we're saying oh but in
the cultural revolution they were
they were called upon by the by the
party by the by the political figures to
go and
and do these things and it's like okay
well maybe in a year they do that maybe
in two years three years
all i know is right now i'm constantly
being told by the press how
trump is an insurrectionist who tried to
overthrow the united states government
and youtube has deleted every iteration
of his speech from cpac
this level of tribalist demonization
isn't stopping it's escalating it's
getting worse
and it seems to me like we we are
dangerously close to this point where
the hysteria reaches this level
perhaps we have a president in joe biden
who he's already failing his first test
in the
in the migrant crisis the left is
outraged over his migrant detention
centers for children
the right is outraged over his releasing
of covet positive patients
covet positive illegal immigrants into
texas as well as shutting down trump's
border wall
so now you've got both sides angry with
him he didn't get the stimulus checks
out
are we potentially looking at a pathetic
and failed leader
who causes widespread just you know just
a
demoralization among even moderates in
this country that results
in donald trump running again in 2024
against the kamala harris who does not
have the charisma to win
trump ends up getting a decisive but
slim victory
and then you have all of that
conditioning over four years of the
demons of the insurrectionists
trump finally completed his interaction
he took the country over we must go we
must purge him to stop this
or perhaps it goes the other way trump
becomes president and says they're the
bad guys they're the ones trying to
subvert it
like the hyper polarization is getting
just that scary to me
well democracy is very fragile and
you know you're mentioning the
commission making the comparison to 911
what's the lesson of 911 the government
used terrorism to create the patriot act
which
was really more about making the
government more powerful and taking away
the rights of
the american people i mean it's it's
about power and control and what you
kind of just described
was a struggle session essentially and
so this is where people need to
learn from history and see the patterns
are these actual threats
that are being discussed or is it just
somebody creating
that opposition that they need to have
the dialectical conflict
well that's it the struggle right
there's something to struggle against
there's an interesting book that that
talks
a lot about this sort of thing i think
you're talking about it's called uh
how the specter of communism is ruling
the world
uh it makes some interesting points um
well people can read that themselves and
draw their conclusions but it looks at
history and you do see
you know there are people who learn from
all of these tactics that have been used
for control and people who want control
they're not idiots
they look at what has worked and what
hasn't worked and refined
the chinese communist party is a much
more refined
soviet union they're not making many of
the same mistakes the soviet union
did because they learned from them
that's why chinese communist party is
still here yeah they constantly talk
about gorbachev and how
nobody can be a gorbachev basically
remember people thought she would be
gorbachev
i remember there was an event held in
d.c a bunch of trump supporters were
protesting against massive multinational
billion dollar corporations
that were suppressing speech political
speech in the us
the trump supporters were protesting and
targeting
billionaires antifa shut up and
physically attacked them it's it's
interesting that
you have this demonization for the
populist right it's the elites it's the
establishment
for the populist left it's the populist
right and i wonder if that's just the
convenient tool
of the establishment to say get these
people to attack them because they're
attacking us
using this idea of the struggle this
this conflict between factions
to make sure nobody actually goes after
them if they keep doing that
well eventually using trump supporters
conservatives and populist right-wingers
as your scapegoat will result in
such extreme hyperpolarization that
people start getting killed we've
already seen
with the riots over last year i think
there was 19 official deaths caused by
the riots
and then there are i believe 11 or 12 uh
about 12 peripheral deaths just out
in like as a result of the rioting some
people died for certain reasons
but then we also had that uh that guy in
portland who took two in the chest from
that antifa guy
with the the he had the black lives
matter tattoo on his neck the revolution
fest
and he shot him twice in the chest when
you say riots you're talking about the
mostly peaceful protests
yes right yes where buildings were on
fire and destroyed and
over two billion dollars in in insurance
payouts
not even the total cost of damage that
we saw and uh
and the the vice president and president
supporting those actions
you know you want you want something
absolutely insane
andrew cuomo there's new report coming
out that
he his administration instructed the
health department
to obscure the amount of people who died
in nursing homes as a result of their
policies
on march 25th of last year cuomo put he
announced this policy to send
covet patients into nursing homes
nursing homes
resisted saying this will introduce the
virus into the most vulnerable
populations
they said so what 15 000 people died
cuomo covered it up and that is
confirmed
one assemblyman has said it's a criminal
a coordinated criminal conspiracy
i've said send the guy to prison andrew
cuomo still enjoys a 65
approval rating and a 60 favorability
rating among democrats
when you have that level of he's been
accused of
harassing women three women have stepped
forward and even
prominent democratic like left-leaning
liberal-type figures in the media are
criticizing him saying
he should resign democrats are saying he
should resign
it is now being reported by mainstream
left right wing publications
he killed these people he covered it up
the democrat voter still favors him 65
percent
so when you have things like that it
says to me like tribalism
owns everything you could have quite
literally when donald trump said i could
shoot somebody on fifth avenue
you weren't kidding that's a good point
yeah tribalism it's it's
it is a tool of dictators it's uh the
more
the less we see each other as fellow
humans
that actually have more in common than
we do differences
that gets easily used when we start to
just see
the other the enemy yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you